Bonjour à tous
Dans une précédente vidéo, j’évoquais l’homme de Cro Magnon et l’image souvent
très stéréotypée que nous en avons.
On pense toujours à un humain archaïque, voûté,
mal dégrossi, avec un énorme bourrelet sur-orbitaire
et c’est souvent ce que la littérature et
le cinéma nous proposent.
Pourtant, cet homme des cavernes, comme on aime à l’appeler,
n’a pas grand-chose à nous envier !
Certains seront peut-être étonnés d’apprendre
que rien ne différencie Albert Einstein ou
Marylin Monroe de M. Cro-Magnon d’il y a
30 000 ans
mais qu’à cela ne tienne, c’est bien ce qu’on va montrer aujourd’hui dans
« la minute nécessaire ».
Cro-Magnon, c’est avant tout le nom d’un
site archéologique et plus précisément
d’un abri-sous-roche situé dans la commune
des Eyzies-de-Tayac en Dordogne.
C’est la commune de France qui abrite sans aucun doute
le plus de sites préhistoriques
et aussi parmi les plus importants.
Dans cet abri Cro-Magnon
ont été trouvés en 1868, cinq squelettes
humains à savoir un vieillard, 2 hommes adultes,
une femme et un fœtus, qui ont été datés
depuis, de la période du Gravettien c'est-à-dire
il y a entre 28 000 et 22 000 ans qui ont
servi à définir l’homme de Cro-Magnon.
Mais alors qu’est-ce que l’homme de Cro-Magnon ?
En réalité, Cro-Magnon c’est nous,
Homo Sapiens.
Pas une version ancienne, pas un ancêtre lointain
mais bien un homme anatomiquement
moderne.
Tellement moderne qu’il n’y aurait aucun moyen de distinguer n’importe quel
individu contemporain
d’un homme de Cro-Magnon.
Et d'ailleurs, le rappeur Booba a tout à
fait raison lorsqu'il affirme que :
c'est Cro-Magnon là.
Là y'a rien, Joey Starr c'est
zéro.
Mais oui, parfaitement, Joey Starr égal Cro-Magnon !
Et ça je sais pas s'il
sait qu'il sait...
Sapiens Sapiens...
En effet, tous les squelettes attribués à Cro-Magnon ont moins de 40 000 ans. Et
40 000 ans, c’est trop court pour que des
modifications morphologiques notables apparaissent.
On a donc pu dire au sujet de Cro-Magnon
dès 1920
En fait, en Préhistoire, à partir de Cro-Magnon, on peut mettre de côté l’évolution
physique.
bah voilà ça y' est, ça bouge plus
pour se concentrer davantage sur les objets que l'homme
fabrique et produit
c’est-à-dire sa culture matérielle
On parle rarement de Cro-Magnon sans évoquer Neandertal et pour cause :
La découverte de Cro-Magnon en Europe faisait
suite à celle de l‘homme de Neandertal
seulement douze ans auparavant, en 1856, dans
l’Ouest de l’Allemagne.
Et lui, pour le
coup était peut-être moins photogénique
car il avait le nez et les dents proéminentes
avec le front fuyant et le crâne allongé
C’est d’ailleurs peut-être de là que viennent
des images préconçues
et si ça se trouve
les images que nous avons de Cro-Magnon sont
celles de Neandertal qui sont déjà des images
faussées voire parfois carrément péjoratives.
On confond aussi très souvent, Cro-Magnon
et Neanderthal même de la part d’éminents
spécialistes. Mais au fond tout ça est très
compliqué, faut être très savant pas du
tout ! Le brave neandertalien avait parfaitement
compris qu'ici c'était plus tempéré qu'ailleurs
qu'il devait y avoir du gibier que c'était
beau et qu'il y faisait bon vivre ! Il faut
bien comprendre que Neandertal n’est absolument
pas un ancêtre de Cro-Magnon. Comme vous
le savez peut-être ces deux types humains
ont cohabité pendant plusieurs millénaires
et se sont même peut-être mélangés. Ce
n'es pas sale ! Cro-Magnon et Neandertal ont
en fait évolué à partir d’un ancêtre
commun : Homo Erectus.
Tenter d’expliquer ce qu’est l’homme
de Cro-Magnon nous oblige à revenir sur nos
origines. Alors ici on va pas s'attarder sur
les descriptions micro détaillées de toutes
les lignées dont on ne sait au final pas grand-chose.
Australopithecus anamensis
Australopithecus
afarensis
Australopithecus bahrelghazali,
Australopithecus garhi
Homo habilis
Homo
rudolfensis
Homo heidelbergensis
Neandertalien,
Herto
Homo sapiens idaltu.
Nous ici on va
plutôt se concentrer sur les trois grandes
espèces qui nous intéressent ici à savoir
Sapiens, Neandertal et Erectus
Nous descendons d’Erectus
Cet ancêtre commun est une espèce africaine.
Il y a environ 1,8 million d’années, des
populations d’Homo erectus sont sorties
d’Afrique, se sont installées en Europe
et sont devenues des Neandertal. D’autres
évolutions locales ont eu lieu en Asie ce
qui sur la carte est appelée E+, mais elles
sont moins connues et ne seront pas détaillées
dans cet épisode. En parallèle, il y a ceux
qui sont restés en Afrique et qui sont devenus
des Cro-Magnon ou Sapiens. Une partie de ces
Sapiens est par la suite sortie d’Afrique,
il y a environ 100 à 150 000 ans et les préhistoriens
appellent ça le « Out of Africa II ».
Au
bout du compte,
Sapiens a fini par remplacer Neandertal en Europe
qui a disparu il y a
environ 30 000 ans.
Cette théorie de l’origine africaine des
lignées humaines était encore discutée
dans les années 1980, mais depuis, les analyses
ADN ont définitivement confirmé cette origine.
Il reste toutefois possible que Sapiens n’ait
pas remplacé les autres peuplements issus
de la première sortie d'Afrique d’Homo
erectus, mais qu’il se soit plutôt hybridé avec les évolutions locales.
We are the world.
En effet, on peut même imaginer, comme le fait Yves Coppens
qu’il n’y ait pas eu
que deux sorties d'Afrique, mais des contacts
constants entre les populations africaines
et asiatiques. Neandertal serait selon cette
théorie, resté isolé en Europe, région
difficilement accessible pendant les glaciations
et n’aurait donc pas pu se mélanger aux
autres populations.
Avant de nous quitter récapitulons les choses:
Cro-Magnon c’est nous, nous sommes issus
de lignées africaines dont l’Histoire reste
encore largement à écrire. Si on admet que
les hommes sont originaires d’Afrique de
l’Est, il faut en revanche être conscient du biais suivant :
Les conditions climatiques, géologiques
en Afrique de l’Est sont propices à la
conservation des restes humains et en particulier
des ossements et c’est pour l’instant
là que se sont concentrées les recherches
scientifiques.
Je ne prétends pas avoir la réponse à la question de nos origines
il y a différentes théories qui sont toujours d'actualité
et que j’ai voulu vous présenter rapidement
et un « rapidement » s’impose, parce qu'il
y a des personnes qui ont passé leur vie
à bosser sur ces questions : donc globalement
résumons, il y a la théorie soutenue par
la génétique celle de la sortie d'Afrique
avec aujourd'hui on le conçoit un peu mieux,
quelques contacts très limités entre les
populations, puis des alternatives comme celle
de Coppens pour qui « L’Afrique ne serait
pas le seul berceau de l’Homme moderne ». La
génétique n’étant pas une science infaillible,
il faut prendre ces résultats avec précautions
et garder à l’esprit que ces conclusions
peuvent être contredites par des découvertes archéologiques.
Au final, peu importe laquelle de ces théories
vous séduira le plus puisque ça ne modifie
en rien le constat suivant :
Il n’y pas de différence morphologique et intellectuelle
entre vous et l’homme d’il y a 40 000
ans. Certains on même pu dire et à juste
titre :
« Si on les avait envoyés à l’école, les premiers sapiens auraient appris à lire
ou à écrire »
Ce qui a changé en 40 000 ans c’est notre culture et notamment
le progrès technique :
de la hache polie et silex taillé à l’arbalète puis aujourd'hui
au missile balistique.
Au fil des générations nous avons fait progresser les techniques.
Et toute la question est là :
à partir de quand considère-t-on que nos ancêtres nous
ressemblent ? A partir du premier ordinateur,
A partir du premier ordinateur, de la première ville, de la première peinture
ou de la maîtrise du feu ?